yeah one of the jobs which John had when
he was in the CIA was to run the Angolan
program
he later quit the CIA and wrote his
famous book in search of enemies John
George Bush is inherited quite a few
covert operations from the Reagan
administration can you provide an
overview of the CIA secret wars under
Reagan and tell us what is likely to
happen with these operations on your
Bush this is the most fascinating period
perhaps of the Cold War because there is
the suggestion the rumor of foot if you
will that the Cold War is coming to an
end
the Russians are withdrawing from the
battlefield and it's all over that's not
going to happen I was just in London
conferring with a number of people
including toady Ben of the Labour Party
talking about just that sort of thing
what Bush is going to do is put the
covert back in covert actions Reagan
wanted to be the cowboy showing the
world how he stood up to communism in
Nicaragua and bombed Libya and did
dramatic things or to put it another way
is bush is going to use Vaseline as he
proceeds with the rate of the world and
get it back into more of an old-school
they're bragging of course big about
Afghanistan Reagan as he went out of
office cited all of his peace victories
Angola you know of course a big one he
was a little bit quiet on Nicaragua
because he had sworn that he would not
go out of office with the Sun and he
stood still in office and they did
outlast him else El Salvador is probably
the hottest spot as I see it if you
measure it in terms of where the United
States might be provoked put in US
troops and have our next war could very
well be El Salvador Kampuchea their
sighting that is another big victory
we've got the Russians withdrawing from
you know the Cubans from Angola the
Soviets from Afghanistan the Vietnamese
from from Kampuchea but as we get into
the discussion you peel off the layer of
the cover story and you start finding
very quickly the cynicism going on full
of pace and the basic point I think that
that I would register
is that we got a lot of energy from reg
reagan's cowboy style he wanted the
world to debate contra aid instead of
focus on the fact that reaganomics had
run up two biggest debt in the history
of the world and so he was focusing
attention there but there were
twenty-one low-intensity conflicts going
at the CIA was a major participant in
and the only one that got any remarkable
coverage and the peace community are the
presses Nicaragua and it was by no means
the biggest in terms of money or in
terms of lives lost now with with the
the Vaseline president we're going to
have the situation working where we may
not have that infusion of energy from
the White House from the Congress giving
us the ammunition for our debates and
rallies and a rallying point for the
Peace Corps a little bit harder for us
to be sure what's happening in in given
countries the sort of thing where it may
come out five years later like like Chad
with Woodward's coverage coming out you
know years later what was that about
well back in the early 80s Woodward's
work Vale there was some coverage at the
time Time Newsweek but the CIA put two
consecutive invasions our forces
together from the Sudan to move into
Chad to take power to counter Qaddafi
and and and his forces coming down from
from Libya at the time it was happening
you don't get the coverage you don't
they keep it secret if they want to the
Afghani operation is the biggest one in
the history of the CIA and they managed
to divert biggest in every sense
including the fact the largest heroin
smuggling ring left behind and they
managed to to keep it from not secret
but keep it from being a focal point of
debate for the six major years that it
was run how could have been bigger than
Vietnam well the UNAM was a CIA
operation for years before they army
came in and Vietnam became the Vietnam
war with billion US Army US Air Force
billions of dollars Laos had always been
cited as the CIA's biggest
or Vietnam became an overt war Laos
remained a CI secret war and the
hundreds of millions of dollars they're
supported with Air Force bombing and
everything but Afghanistan is they
haven't published the figure I've never
been able to find anyone who confident
like the archives national security art
guys got Armstrong in Washington a solid
figure on how much they've spent in
Afghanistan but it's in the billions and
lets latest in the history let's go into
Afghanistan in some detail I read in the
New York Times just this morning that
the Reagan administration was bragging
that they refused to compromise with the
Soviet Union to pull out their support
for the Afghan rebels in exchange for
the Soviets pulling out so let's see who
the u.s. actually was supporting in
Afghanistan over the last years what of
the rebel forces how they were
supporting them and what the effects of
this have already been and might be as
we now are moving to a new era for
Afghanistan there could be total chaos
looks like the Lebanon ization of
Afghanistan yeah all these different
groups they have well there's all these
different rebel groups who is the u.s.
supporting out of the whole spectrum I
bet I saw him on TV yesterday there was
a guy they found who spoke good English
he was clean-shaven and looked at like
all like sighs I typed from the
Philippines they I'm going to hedge a
little bit because this is not an area
of my primary expertise and I've not
been able to travel there and look at it
like I did Nicaragua and El Salvador and
Angola and all of that but it you
essentially have it we do have it we the
the Admiral Turner when when I debated
him at Colby College he cited he was
boasting about that covert action that
he had started it and citing it as an
example of a successful covert operation
they set it in motion and then
eventually it led to the Soviets having
to withdraw their troops the game that
they're playing essentially the u.s. the
parallel to Vietnam is significant we
invaded they invaded or barked each
created government
that invited us in so to speak the
difference is in the break-up of course
at the NLF would not compromise in
Vietnam the the Tom Polgara scandal
we've talked about before the chief of
station hoping they would give the u.s.
a break and they had no reason to they
had the u.s. down and dirty and we're
going to humiliate us as effectively as
they could this is essentially what
Reagan is doing in Afghanistan but the
difference is that in Vietnam the other
side had had created a very cohesive
force - in an orderly way to move in and
take power and administrate and run the
country the NLF and Hanoi and the
government and everything what we've
been doing in Afghanistan is just pure
and simple
shotgun destabilization funding anybody
that's got a group giving them arms
through Pakistan every kind of group as
you say the Lebanon's a ssin so that now
we where we've won in the sense that
that Reagan is crowing and Turner is
growing and Carter is growing he's you
heard that on the news yesterday that
his policies had been vindicated and all
of that and the Russians are pulling out
admitting that they made a big mistake
in fact they're probably being more
candid than we were when we pulled out
of here Nam right we tried to say was an
honorable this and everything they're
just saying flat we made a mistake
tragic mistake but we have not created a
force our government or a movement or
anything that believes in anything to
step into the vacuum I debated our I
thought I was going to debate an Afghani
professor at the world affairs
conference in Boulder last year and who
because he was paid working for the VOA
and US propaganda arm so I presumed he
was bought and paid for and he kept
telling me you know just let me finish
my sentence so to speak and I did and
what he said is what that what the
powers have done is condemned
Afghanistan to eternal violence and
conflicts it looks like it's going to be
horrible they're pulling out and and
this side is not going to agree to
relent and the Soviets are going to
see what they would call a necessity to
keep arming the other side this is where
you get into a test if you will of
Gorbachev sincerity and bushes you know
kinder gentler you know goodness in the
nation do they really mean it they're
trying to convince the world that the
Cold War is winding Doonesbury is
already told as Cold War is over it
isn't now the danger of course is that
people are so eager craving for hope and
craving for peace it doesn't take much
as dynamic as the peace movement
arguably is in the United States and and
Europe for example it sure doesn't take
much for a president to get up there in
just three words kinder gentler and then
the goodness goodness and greatness for
words and people oh wow you know yeah
whereas the actual policies are to keep
pilin sand covert operations and secret
Wars going so your point about the US
intervention in Afghanistan rather than
negotiating a peaceful settlement we're
negotiating some sort of a governmental
structure we just supported any forces
whatsoever to create chaos in the region
to humiliate the Soviet Union that was
the goal and continues to be the goal of
the Bush administration that continues
to fund the Afghan rebels to make sure
there's more murder chaos etc there what
does bush how can he justify continuing
to support the Afghan rebels now that
the Soviet Union has pulled out there's
no longer a foreign oppressor
well this is just this is just classic
Gold Cold War the elephants fighting you
know in the grass getting trampled we
haven't had our victory over there yet
I'm putting it in in their terms in
Bush's terms the sea eyes terms it is in
the process of happening we haven't
taken Kabul yet we haven't installed any
kind of a government the other than what
the Soviets left behind and so they're
pressing ahead and it's going to be very
much in Bush's interest to try to
get them to moderate the violence the
bloodiness of the revolution the last
great successful revolution from the
other side was the Sandinistas and they
abolished the death sentence the thing
that's happening now with the US forces
us-backed forces as they say in
Afghanistan apparently is just utter
atrocities when they take a city and
then and then they lose it perhaps
they're great crates full of dismembered
bodies you know meat stuck in crates of
hundreds of bodies left behind horror
beyond comprehension perpetrated by the
rebels either by the us-backed forces
the different ones rather than different
ones there's no one force that the u.s.
expects will take over no the u.s. is
working very hard I'm sure to try to get
it so they have some secret strategy or
some forces that they hope absolutely
take over absolutely they hope to take
the capital and establish a government
and then reinforce that government as it
dominates the others and establishes
some kind of peace in the country the
process is going to be extremely bloody
and the US will be doing its very best
with the US media probably not giving us
the vivid clippings of the horrors you
know as they're happening just as
they're not doing it in El Salvador
Guatemala today but could there be an
embarrassment for the u.s. if it turns
out to be a bloodbath that the
us-supported rebels turn out to be
barbaric and there's atrocities
committed everywhere well there is a
bloodbath kept bragging right now and
it's just not being run in our meat
immediate and I mean not being told to
play us in the sea I have done this
continually through the years that's
absolute nom in Iran with a Shah in El
Salvador with different degrees all the
time and with different degrees of
collusion from the press and and in in
Central America for example in 81 when
when Reagan was first plunging in the
media they had crews all over Nicaragua
they had permanent offices set up for
all the biggies in the Intercontinental
Hotel
then after the Falkland Islands they
made a decision and didn't send them
back the stuff was running on the
evening news every day the horror
stories and visual imagery and they shut
it off as the media bought into Reagan's
country program and and you know the
office of public diplomacy in painting
the white hats as they put it on the
Contras and the black hats on the
Sandinistas and the media The Washington
Post the big E's cooperating and they're
clearly cooperating in Afghanistan
otherwise we would be having much more
graphic footage and graphic explanations
of what's happening in Afghanistan right
now today and it's going to get worse
for that yeah for the whole they call
you're treating fighters and that's it
there's been nothing on us support of
any specific groups or what the effects
of supporting these groups are different
exactly what I'm plug this is the
biggest one in the history of the CIA
and there's been nothing about it and
part of the reason is it's been a full
bipartisan the contra program was public
and there was debate on it and at times
it was voted down and close there was
serious differences in the Afghani it's
virtually unanimous both sides of the
house and the Congress or the senator
are fully behind it and so there has and
the administration didn't want to
provoke a debate on it and the media was
willing to to go ahead and give us a
glimpse down and but not map it out for
us
humanely the glimpse of the Soviet
atrocities more it appears that it was
the Soviet occupation that's creating
all of the bloodshed this is a
legitimate revolutionary or counter
revolutionary force but they don't go
into any detail of how the u.s. is
supporting these groups and there's also
nothing about the drug-running of these
different rebel drugs to say the and of
course there's nothing about the CIA
actually helping these rebel forces with
their drug running to help support their
military struggles against the Soviet
without mention of the CI program and
the secret war you do pick up articles
about you know the drug allocations
around the world or
and the the golden Crescent is now the
largest source of heroin apparently in
the world today right in there where the
sea-ice been running this operation with
its c-130s and c-123
flying in with arms and flying out with
the heroin that's the evidence that
that's happening and I haven't even read
anything about this the CIA heroin route
and well there been a lot of things in
covert action information bulletin where
they traced well first of all
historically the rebels that the groups
have been big dope operators for years
and this is one of the things that the
the communist government which later
became backed by the Soviet Union was
trying to do away with they were trying
to eliminate drugs from their country
they were trying to have established
health and education they were trying to
have some women's lib give them a chance
and do away with his layer of right but
when they started doing this and
eliminate some of those drug runners
well then that's one of them big groups
this it's so it's it's sufficiently
flagrant and open and that it was the
theme of the last James Bond as a matter
of fact said in Afghanistan with his
huge plane loads of heroin John there's
a byproduct of this we're assuming that
the activities of the CIA in Afghanistan
will lessen someone as a result of this
do you suppose not for two or three
years no they'll be very busy funding
the CIA and the paramilitary the
invisible government the entire spectrum
of it to build a solid government that
that with the death squads to pacify the
country I look for a tremendously
troubled situation to go on several
years so best I see like Lebanon with
every single faction fighting in a
situation where no faction can gain
control as that Afghani professor said
with with just visible anguish he said
they have condemned Afghanistan to
eternal violence Wow
so there won't be any unemployed covert
action
dogs from the CIA who be available and
looking for work in the rest of the work
knowing that like it happen to be a
non-parent know they'll just be they'll
just be quieter and and that will be the
difference they'll try to keep it out of
sight instead of like the contra program
posturing for the press and provoking
public confrontations let's look at
another place South Africa South Africa
is so-called getting out of Angola but
they did before and they came right back
in again when there was it looked like
they were going to be peace in the area
now looks like the same thing happened
they had they they're getting the Cubans
to pull out they got their ears pinned
back
they pulled away but now I understood
the heard where they've actually made
some more armed attacks already going
three three weeks ago in London and the
interviews and discussions this is very
much what we were talking about was was
what is the guarantee that South
Africa's going to respect this the
Cubans pull out South Africa pulls out
what's going to keep South Africa is
violating every international law and
boundary in southern Africa what's going
to keep him from going back into Angola
how long will it be before they put
their troops back in an answer was two
weeks yeah and now interestingly enough
Washington's reaction on this of course
Reagan had a big aid program to Savimbi
and Bush has promised to continue it and
obviously he's clearly doing so now
Savimbi's pinned down on the border down
there now militarily and it is a little
better off than the Contras are and he
was taking a beating so the South
African forces came in to bail him out
the US response they obviously didn't
stand up and say well we happen to be in
there in force with the CIA and we call
the South Africans in there their
statement was I can just remember you
know back in a task force scribbling
away the wording on the statement you
know put mine you were running tango
when we were running their answer was
that it has not been confirmed by any
reliable sources that the South Africans
are in fact back in Angola which they
aren't fact tell our audience that john
stockwell was the CIA
officer in charge of the Angola
operation and resigned after that wrote
his book in search of enemies that began
his process of developing a criticism of
the CIA and has been speaking out as a
peace activist ever since so Angola has
basically been a hot point for the whole
Reagan administration
well let's strip Angola down just real
briefly while we're on the subject
Chester Crocker Assistant Secretary of
State for African affairs was talking to
some of us any africanist progressive
side of things Gerry bender particulate
the international school at USC and
promising that he was going to negotiate
a settlement for a Namibia and get the
Cubans out of Angola and Gerry who my a
friend whom I respect enormous Lee said
that you know if you succeed we'll give
you credit for it publicly and Crocker
succeeded he pounded away and negotiated
away and it took six years and
eventually he worked out a deal where
the South Africans would give Namibia
its independence and the Cubans would go
home and the Cubans are going home and
it's a real deal and the South Africans
are you know there is at least some kind
of a farcical independence being given
to Namibia the oversight is it going to
work are the UN forces going to cover it
our death squads going to be left behind
to keep a proxy control you know that
question remains but still bender and
and I supporting him were obliged to say
yes you know Crocker you did you did it
Namibia finally is getting its
independence however in that fascinating
complex deal the Cubans are coming home
South Africa is giving independence to
Namibia and and getting out of Angola
and promising to stay out even but the
United States although arbitrating that
thing did not promise to cease its aid
to Savimbi to destabilize Angola
now that is brass but it's also just
idiotic I mean it just it sort of
confirms your thesis in search of
enemies that the role of the CIA is to
search out enemies to fight wars to
stabilized the world here's a region
that needs stability
there's negotiations to try to stabilize
it and the u.s. keeps supporting these
rebel forces to try to overthrow the
Angola government that led to the the
absolutely bizarre situation of the
Cubans there that were supporting the
Soviet backed Angolan government
protecting the US multinational
corporations
I think golf well had big old floor
which is load up the Chevron that the
Cubans were protecting against the CIA
back and goal and rebel forces so
there's not even in US economic interest
when this is equalized I go and sivb was
brought to Washington in the winter of
86 remember he he was he was he dined at
the White House and yet he went on
television promising the aid that he was
being given that he would attack Gulf
oil facilities which facilities had been
built by loans which Reagan had approved
in addition to which he has kept the
central part of Angola frozen and the
Benguela railroad shut and that's as a
year a big clients only economically
viable egress to the sea is that
railroad that we pay Savimbi to keep
shut meanwhile the human horror the Red
Cross counts 55,000 people in Angola who
have been maimed by Savimbi's landlines
and attack and George Bush continues to
support those forces John one of the
analyses that I heard about the the
situation was that there was pressure
within South Africa to get out they
wanted to get out of the Angolan
situation they didn't want to support it
financially and also there were problems
because their soldiers were getting
killed so the United States said okay go
ahead and pull out will come in and will
directly supervise the situation and
take care of it so it wasn't a big
victory for the Angolan government or
for Cuba in that respect it was just a
switch of people who were going to
control it
well this yeah this is exactly the point
I was trying to make is that US Crocker
playing big arbitrator and we didn't
agree to give the region peace but it is
a fact that know maybe is getting
it's independence the the South Africa
is going to try to do what we did to
Nicaragua 1933 when we pull the Marines
out and created the guard and left it
behind
with Somoza you know and charge they're
trying to create the same type of a
situation and have a proxy control of it
from the Cuban point of view the
Angolans are being left facing a dire
situation with Savina be still being
funded to destabilize and the South
Africans still coming across the border
and the Cubans coming home and in Cuba's
interests and and it's it's very
difficult to fault them because they've
they sacrificed a lot of their own and
their own capital to the extent that
they can and they're not a wealthy
country to stick up for their allies the
Angolans but this is the point at which
they could in fact come home with having
accomplished you know immeasurable
objectives that is Namibia is
independent because of what they did yet
the independence of Namibia or any
country in Africa is precarious because
of the CIA presence there whenever an
independent African nation takes a
socialist road or a road that goes
against the interests or ideologies of
the CIA they destabilize the government
Kwame Nkrumah wrote a book called class
struggles in Africa that documented the
ways of the CIA overthrew about
twenty-five progressive governments in
Africa including and chromazone Guardian
government in the 1960s so if Namibia
takes a route that the CIA doesn't like
they can act to destabilize it one way
or the other so that's really the
precarious situation that all
independent nations in Africa face this
is one of Chomsky's best points is that
when the US when a country tries to
escape our first effort is to bludgeon
them back into the fold and if that
fails as it did in Cuba conspicuously as
it did in Vietnam conspicuously as it's
done in Angola to date and Nicaragua
today then the fall
is to starve them out create economic
chaos so that they will not be a
positive example to anyone else to want
to break free and this is this is what
Nicaragua is facing today they won the
first round they survived six years of
constant heavy duty military
destabilization of the countryside the
Contras collapsed in corruption and
chaos and shambles and their own
cowardice and now a plan is afoot to
disband them all together disband the
camps and everything but Nicaragua is
now going to face a vigorous
destabilization from the US government
there's this flora Lewis op-ed piece it
was in The New York Times a couple of
days ago the Austin american-statesman
today where she summarizes the situation
a good piece well done
except she talks about freedom of the
press and she mentions La Prensa and she
does not mention the fact that it was
funded by the CIA during this whole
period and they were Pro count rendering
the whole absolutely a CI propaganda
piece to destabilize the country
creating a war know last week they were
fighting for their survival
she should have mentioned that it's a
good article I compliment her but still
that little detail and then she doesn't
project it further the melding plan
hasn't mentioned where the Ambassador
was was funding that during the height
of peace talks and the Contras and
amnesty Contras in the the embassy was
caught funding people and organizing
them to agitate into violence to remove
US Embassy was finding best relevant
opposition let's focus on his country a
thing for a while I read today in The
New York Times that the Bush
administration seemed to be surprised
that the leaders of the Central American
government had the audacity to shut down
the contrast as how long they had to
leave on Duras evidently the Reagan Bush
administration thought they'd cut a deal
with the Honduran government that the
Contras could stay there as long as
money was being funneled into Honduras
and evidently the Bush administration
was caught by surprise with this meeting
and doesn't exactly know how to react
how do you read this situation every
mine's me of an old saw the bendy in the
third world saying you can you can rent
us some times but you can't buy us and
every time under in generals would need
you know and put some more money in the
bank accounts they would talk about
throwing the Contras out and it is an
embarrassment to them flagrant violation
of all of their own internal laws and
the international agreements in Central
America and but each time they would
propose to close down the Contra bases
Reagan would hit him with another 20 mil
in cash to the generals and and quiet
him down for another year and I would
have to say that either the forces of
peace and Central America are sufficient
that Honduras really is trying to get
rid of this embarrassment or the
generals won another payment do you
think the bush will the Bush
administration will try to buy them off
how would they do it would they have to
go to Congress for money or could they
just say well they have all kinds of
contingency funds and you can you know
20 million they could squeeze up but we
let's watch and see is Reagan going to
hit the Honduran government with a lump
of money or is he going to let them
close down the Contra bases what is the
military situation with the Contras I
gained the impression that the Contras
have pretty much closed down in terms of
interventions into Nicaragua that for a
while there were quite an active
fighting force but this is pretty much
wound down now is it that they're
demoralized they've left the region they
don't have the funding and supplies what
is the situation
no disintegration two years ago the Sun
and East 'iz were giving them credit for
some pretty serious activity and up and
down through the country reaching pretty
far in they were not standing up to the
Sun Anita's in any pitched battles but
their raids and hitting and running
there was there was quite a bit of
energy now there are occasional
atrocities measured you know inside
Nicaragua were there apparently a band
here or there but the leadership has
collapsed they have a sense the u.s. is
going to drop funding them that we've
shut down the great Air Wing that was
that was funding on
through the drug money the leaders are
looking for everybody scurrying to make
sure they have some money in the bank so
they can retire and those soldiers that
were you know expected to go and live in
the jungle with without being resupplied
without the planes coming in to get them
the thing is probably down to five
percent or less of the energy that they
had two years ago and then the talk
about just disbanding the camps
altogether and this is enough of the
little things you signal as you look for
here and there that you know what's
really going on Reagan in his last
couple of months commented that the
United States should be willing to
accept the Contras up here and that's
pretty much of an admission on his part
that you know that they have to go
somewhere boy that's something that just
galls me every time there's the u.s. of
the CIA II lose a big one we bring in
all of these murderers and dope dealers
and people who committed horrible
butcheries and atrocities we welcome
them back into our country where they
continue to do the same thing here which
is precisely isn't it the issue down in
South Texas right now the so-called
Nicaraguan refugees coming up here the
ones who are supposedly fleeing the
Sandinistas these were clearly contra
supporters and the US has not really got
that clear of policy in fact the only
group that we just totally welcomed was
the Cuban exile group that we had run
from Florida that has been a constant
embarrassment to the United States
government and the source of a major
uppy upheaval and crime and drug
smuggling and there's quite a block of
sane people in this country not of our
politics but nevertheless sane who are
saying we don't want him up here we
don't need another mafia we have a
Vietnamese mafia Sudan mafia anyone any
way I mean some of them have read
Christopher Dickies book you know with
with the Contras about his patrol about
less we see does just this and what's
credible vendetta and orgy of violence
down in the country and no we don't want
these people up here but you see the
Honduran government
I want the neither you remember the
maybe we can make a master NOS and shoot
them out into space the Kurds it's they
call it the disposals Afghanistan the
disposable you have the Kurds of course
in Iran Iraq and Henry Kissinger's
famous statement when we were winding
that one down and the Shah said it's not
my problem you've got to deal with them
and Kissinger recommended the Congress
that we let him go he said that
corporate action is not to be confused
with missionary work so essentially the
Kurds were just dropped and slaughtering
and slaughtered John let's talk about El
Salvador now use you said at the start
of the program that that was going to be
the next big big place of contention
what has happened there that's different
it's it's it's returned to the same a
New York Times International Herald
Tribune are writing repeated articles
saying that the level of violence and
dispute and instability in the country
is back to where it was in 1982 when it
was about to go down the tubes it was it
was all it was breaking the country
could have gone a revolution could have
happened and the US began putting in
massive shipments that eventually became
three point three billion dollars worth
of military aid these big newspapers are
sort of warning the establishment that
that's where we are right now today
counting the number of attacks on
military camps by the so-called rebels
in the capital you know in the last
month and elections are coming up in
which there is every appearance that the
audrina party will win which is the
right-wing you know doubly son's
original creation and this this is a
situation where I think Bush is really
desperate I think you know his Vaseline
principal putting the covert back in it
I don't think he wants a showdown in El
Salvador right now he wants to sell this
goodness for a while longer and keep
things quiet until he's got his
credibility up but one thing that I said
in England that I fear very much is the
reason he and the media that supports
him are working so hard on this goodness
image is so that when he puts US troops
into El Salvador to keep it
going down the tubes he'll be able to
say I'm a good guy but you know I had to
or to put it another way he's faced with
a dire challenge to his a his first real
test there if the country comes apart if
it starts to go if the revolution starts
to really succeed the oligarchy is
already back to the 82 position of D
capitalization of taking their money out
in case it blows so they won't be caught
with it in the sense of adore banks if
it goes then he's going to have to
either one put US Marines in there had
just a point in history where the
Soviets are pulling theirs out of
Afghanistan and the world's not going to
like that and the people in the US
aren't going to like that or he's going
to take historical credit for quote
letting El Salvador go down the tubes as
Carter was blamed for example for for
Iran and Nicaragua and he's not going to
want to do that he's not going to be
comfortable you know the conservative
element of his being and his his
presidency they're not going to be happy
to let a revolution actually happen in
El Salvador I see them as utterly
desperate right now trying to work out
some kind of a compromise and keep the
lid on how can they do that if the rebel
forces are about to win a military
battle is there a possibility of
negotiating a settlement this is one
thing that the Bush Reagan force has
just haven't done they have always used
the big stick I mean covert Secret Wars
has been their method and you know you
notice in El Salvador and this is just
in the last few weeks the rebels
proposed to participate in the elections
if the elections can be put back six
months so they'll have time to
realistically and duarte immediately
said no absolutely not that would be
unconstitutional no way and Bush his
White House said well slow down maybe we
can find a well you think they may be
forced to negotiate for the first time
our faces are desperate decision one
that could be be a Bay of Pigs kind of a
humiliation for George Bush in the early
days of his presidency but it's another
state of chaos right now and
Salvador's and I only have the rebel
forces winning victories but the death
squads from what I read are also back in
the play so that in the city you have
these right-wing death squads carrying
out wholesale assassinations and Bush's
options are pretty limited the arena
party it appears is going to win if they
do there their inclination to violence
of course is well known and they're
already into violence the Congress is in
a mood to cut off their military aid if
the violence level goes up to a point
beyond which they can no longer ignore
it and but if you cut away the military
aid then you don't have any carrot as
they put it to induce them to behave
themselves so the promise as as they are
threatening is said well in that case
you know there would be no reason for us
to restrain our soldiers and a great
bloodbath might ensue so El Salvador as
as a result of in part of our meddling
and policies and support of creation
originally in the 60s of the death
squads and in support of them through
today is faced with a real terrible
threat of a major upheaval like like
occurred in the 30s for another
bloodbath where the oligarch water on
where the oligarchy got together in the
30s and said we're going to kill 30,000
people to keep the lid on things and
that's about where they are right now
and that's what they did that's what
they did John there is another
occurrence of a socialist government
pulling out of a neighbor we mentioned
it briefly before Cambodia when the Pol
Pot regime was there and just murdering
people by the millions
the Vietnamese went in and stabilize the
country and put in a government then the
United States and the Chinese supported
Pol Pot the absolute butcher now the
Vietnamese are pulling out of Cambodia
now what what's what's going to happen
there is it going to be a bloodbath like
you remembered like Afghanistan you
spoke your remember I said back when
three big failures of the Carter
Administration from my point of view
the contradictions that represented a
betrayal one of them was was sketching
the the Olympics for political reasons
which was betraying the Athletics and
the peace athletic process of the world
another one was supporting Pol Pot the
greatest mass murderer of modern times
after Henry Kissinger supporting him as
the legitimate government at the United
Nations when he had no power whatsoever
inside the country but Jimmy Carter did
that and the third thing of course was
suing me and taking my profits away from
my book and putting me under a court
order those were the reasons why I
couldn't vote for Jimmy Carter Haiti
election so what are the fruits of this
kind this year's policy for years we've
been it must be ten years now we've been
supporting Paul Pott along with the
Chinese of the Chinese still behind him
- or they finally shamed into dropping
this character now what they've got is
four four factions that are vying for
power and the u.s. is actually made some
policy statement saying that Paul Pott
cannot be in charge of the of the
winning faction but but we it once again
we've created forces now mind you I was
on my way back to Vietnam and 85 the
Vietnamese were opening up ten year
anniversary and the US media went in and
I went back with my lead to visit her
family and while we were traveling
William Casey and George Shultz toured
the area and in Bangkok announced a new
destabilization program against Vietnam
in Cambodia so we have created now
putting our money in willy-nilly we've
created several factions and the
Vietnamese not that we've rocked their
boat very successfully in Kampuchea but
the Russian economic policy the Russia
was underwriting that totally Viet Nam's
on its knees economically and Russia was
bankrolling that and the Russians
decided that that's one place they can
cut you know some of their losses and
also win some goodwill with the United
States so the Vietnamese are pulling out
and we do not have control
we have created something that we don't
have control of with every possibility
that we're going to see another major
bloodbath in Kampuchea for which we will
be in part responsible in fact going
back I guess it's nineteen early 70s
Kampuchea was pretty much out of the
South East Asian Wars until Nixon
started secretly bombing the country
because he thought that North Vietnamese
and Vietcong forces were using Cambodia
as a sanctuary and because of US
bombings that country was destabilized
and got into a situation of total chaos
was one of the most peaceful most
beautiful countries in the world that
the bombings plus the CIA creation of
the laudanol government which went into
the outer corruption the standard
pattern and this reminds me by the way
in in London some of the peace activists
they might my conditions going over
there as I would give four lectures
including the one in the House of
Commons but that they would talk to me
fifty percent of the time so I would get
their input and which was really useful
to me getting Tony Benn to give his
assessment of where socialism is going
and where capitalism is going and where
the Soviet Union is going but they came
to the hotel and played a video they
gave it the hotel and hotel put it on
their internal video so I could watch it
on a TV narrated by Eartha Kitt called
after the fire which is a study of the
environmental war we waged in Vietnam
and the [ __ ] children that are
being born today and in my own province
and pain in where I was the officer in
charge they interviewed a nurse there
was a midwife with two assistants the
only medical help in the province and
they were saying that that when a woman
comes to us pregnant we asked her where
she lives and we can tell her
automatically whether or not she has a
good chance of delivering a normal child
just by where she lives all the chemical
warfare in Vietnam has
destroyed this parts of the environment
this was the the two greatest moments of
shock that I felt as I've come into the
peace movement one of them was seeing
the the the children in 83 I went down
and actually held main children in
Nicaragua and the second one was seeing
this film and just seeing what we
deliberately did to the environment
killing the thousand-year-old trees and
permanently poisoning a land and seeing
the the photograph you know the shots of
the of the children that had been born
since John is there any possibility of
stopping the CIA wars we've seen the
fruits that they bear which is death
mayhem destruction chaos etc is it
possible to stop Bush and the secret
Wars Bush himself was head of the CIA
he's obviously someone deeply committed
to covert action while he smiles and
talks about a kinder gentler nation he's
supporting all of these CIA operations
and he's been open and truthful about he
says he supports him that can this be
stopped I mean could is there a mood in
Congress or elsewhere in the country
that these are not helping anyone they
don't serve any real US interest they
just destabilize and create chaos and
death
they're totally amoral they're
irrational is there any sense that this
is what's really going on and then it
just has to be stopped well I'm going to
go ahead and WEP is evidently trying to
create a sane or more rational Soviet
policy so shouldn't the counterpart of
that be in the u.s. to stop these covert
wars well I hate to keep pounding away
like doctor gloom but even even glass
toast you know there's a downside of
glass nose we do have like I say
doonesbury announced the end of the Cold
War the nation we've gotten the word out
there is a great movement in the nation
if you will of a revulsion of saying
these things are wrong they're
surprising people in the establishment
bill Colby who ran the Phoenix program
and the CI is it did all these things
said the country program was wrong and
should be shut down and then said that
covert action should be gotten out of
the CIA you're finding remarkable people
saying that acknowledging the fact that
these things are wrong what they're
doing however as I say is just putting
the covert back into them and toning
them down a little bit and trying to
keep them out of the public
consciousness in trying to get the major
media to cooperate with them and keeping
them out of the public consciousness I
have to mention however the downside of
glass nose twitch people are overlooking
as the Soviet Union invites openness and
discussion everything but in the 7th of
January that was a utterly remarkable
op-ed piece in The New York Times which
is a reprint from the Soviet foreign
ministry journal from last summer done
by Andrzej acquisitive in which he said
look most of the third world has opted
for the capitalist solution it was a
mistake for the United for the USSR to
support people's movements around the
world it led us into the nuclear arms
race that's almost broken the Soviet
economy and in the Soviet economic
interest we he says have to start
supporting stability and the status quo
in the third world and and join in the
capitalist process in order to
participate in world trade in order to
recover our own economy and economic
interests now on the one hand we should
have a celebration because he's an
engorged chef at the United Nations said
something comparable now you know your
first reaction is let's go out and have
a celebration because this does would
seem to offer a hope that the thing kept
the Cold War the brutalization of these
countries can be shut down with the
Soviet initiative and people fatigued of
them in the United States the problem is
this there are two kinds of covert
actions to oversimplify basically you
see them clearly anika in Central
America Nicaragua with a contra
freedom-fighters destabilization force
and in El Salvador where we spent 3.3
billion dollars on the death squad
to maintain the status quo to keep a
revolutionary forces from when keep the
people suppressed to keep the
oligarchies in power to keep the dollars
flowing to keep the trade flowing at
whatever price to the people now if the
Soviet Union proceeds to do what it's
discussing publicly doing it is openly
saying that it's going to be cooperating
with the United States colluding with
the United States to support for the El
Salvador's if you will to support the
status quo which means there won't be
anyone
a major superpower supporting the
people's interests and the people's
aspirations and hopes and the two
superpowers will be colluding to have
better trade to dominate the third world
this would be a great step in the
direction of the world security state I
mean you've got you know let us not
forget wonderful as he may be but an
ex-kgb guy and Moscow and an ex-cia
director as president here and that
right right there tells you quite a bit
about the movement of the world not to
mention the great you know peace Nick in
London I said that short Gorbachev is a
shady background yeah and this it wasn't
this Henry Kissinger's vision of the
world the US and the Soviet Union have a
lot of common interests and they should
get together and sort of divide up the
world where each has their sphere of
influence
Kissinger of course studied 19th century
Europe where they had carving up of
Europe and spheres of influence so this
has been his policies well as a matter
of fact Kissinger published a paper
co-authored paper which is discussed I
believe it's in the December issue of
the progressive magazine in which he's
saying how the US Bush we just won the
election should prepare to fight wars in
the third world that the Soviet Union
mentioning specific weapons systems that
have been designed to fight Soviets in
Russia in Europe but how they could be
reintegrated to fight wars in the third
world well that's more aggressive than
kissing gears earlier yeah pause so he's
flat saying that the the next wars will
be in the third
world as we cooperate with the Soviet
Union wow that's heavy well John thank
you for your gloom and doom but heck you
got a look at the world the way it is
don't you we've got a lot of work to do
we've got a lot of work to do we can't
forget that the INF treaty gave us all
so much hope but the factories are
spitting out bombs faster than they've
ever been and they're now nine nations
producing bombs well it shows we have to
reveal what's going on in these
different CIA operations all over the
world to try to publicize them so
hopefully people will be horrified if
they know the truth of what's going on
and their human consequences of these
covert actions and just simply shut down
these secret Wars yes amen